- DUDE, ADAM BETTER HURRY UP.
IT'S LIKE THE GUY NEVER
LISTENS TO ME.
- [making flatulence noises]
CHAPSTICK.
- OKAY, I'M GOING TO
SOCK YOU IN THE MOUTH
IF YOU DON'T CUT IT OUT
WITH THAT CRAP!
- IT'S NOT CRAP, IT'S FARTS.
- WHOA! T.M.I.
THAT STANDS FOR
TOO MUCH INFORMATION.
- OH, WE WEREN'T EVEN--THAT'S--
- OH, I DON'T CARE.
COME ON, HAVE A SEAT.
NOT THIS ONE.
[chuckles]
- OKAY.
- LITTLE B.G. ON ME...
I DO H.R.
MEANS HUMAN RESOURCES
HERE AT T.A.C.
MY NAME IS ERIC ROSSDALE.
SOME PEOPLE CALL ME "COOL ERIC."
THEY CALLED ME THAT ONCE.
SOME YOUNG PEOPLE TOO.
SOME YOUNG--SOME--
ONE YOUNG PERSON DID THAT.
I LOVE PEOPLE.
TO SAY THAT ANOTHER WAY,
I LOVE PEOPLE!
THAT ONE'S GOT A LITTLE MORE
FUN TO IT, DOESN'T IT?
OKAY, WE ARE HERE TODAY...
- UH...
- WHY ARE YOU POINTING AT US?
- HELP OUT
WITH SUBSTANCE ABUSE--
WELL, I'M JUST TRYING TO
BRING EVERYBODY INTO IT.
HELP OUT WITH SUBSTANCE ABUSE.
OKAY? AND HOW DO I
DO THAT?
WELL, ONE WAY IS
TO WORK THROUGH THIS WORKBOOK,
START TO FINISH.
WE DO EVERY SINGLE DRILL
IN THIS THING.
I SIGN A PIECE OF PAPER SAYING
YOU'VE CLEANED UP YOUR ACT,
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY,
WE HAVE DUG OUT
THE ROOTS
OF YOUR ADDICTION.
AND YOU'RE LOOKING AT ME
LIKE "WHAT HAPPENED TO THAT GUY
WE CALLED COOL
TWO SECONDS AGO?"
HE'S RIGHT HERE.
HOW 'BOUT THIS INSTEAD?
HOW 'BOUT WE FIRE UP SOME
STEP BROTHERS ON THE BLU-RAY,
WE CHILL OUT A LITTLE BIT...
HOW DOES THAT SOUND TO YOU?
- YEAH, THAT SOUNDS...AWESOME.
- YEAH.
- OKAY, GREAT.
BEFORE WE START, LET ME DO
SOME ATTENDANCE, IF THAT'S OKAY.
UH, BLACK ANDERSON.
- UH, I--I THINK THAT'S ME.
- OH, TERRIFIC. OH,
'CAUSE OF THE CURLY HAIR,
LIKE A BLACK MAN.
THAT'S FUN.
ANDERS HOLMVIK.
- YEAH, RIGHT HERE.
- YEAH, NORWEGIAN.
- YEAH.
- YEAH. HVORDAN GAR DET?
- OH, IS THAT--
NO, I DON'T SPEAK...
- HVORDAN GAR DET?
- MUCH OF THE LANGUAGE.
- OH. OH, YOU SHOULD.
OH, NO,
IT'S A BEAUTIFUL COUNTRY.
AND ADAM DEMAMP.
- ACTUALLY, ADAM'S RUNNING
A LITTLE--
- UH, I AM ADAM.
- WELL, I HOPE YOU LIKE
SANDWICHES, ADAM,
'CAUSE I GOT A BACKPACK
FULL OF 'EM.